How long one stays in parasympathetic mode after coffee in a month. I don't know, I don't know that that's ever been measured.
It's again, it's, it's your, you're always fluctuating between sympathetic told, you're never completely just sitting there balanced parasympathetic sympathetic balance if you could put it on a scale.
body's always shifting and movie, that's what you're supposed to be. You hear a siren, your sympathetic kick in. Well, some people's sympathetic kick in when they hear a siren and they stay stuck in sympathetic mode for the rest of the day, because they're living in such sympathetic told with so much stress all the time.
There was some research back and over years ago that showed what a person has a sympathetic stimulation. It could last X about a hours, but it was at a very, I think a poor quality study with not a lot of participants in it. It was, it's difficult to measure that with, you know, a serious degree of accuracy.
So, you know, I wouldn't put too much faith on that. It's about practicing parasympathetic stimulation, practicing call me down, trying to live a life that's calmer, trying to get out and grow to yourself, trying to get out in nature, trying to, to put your trust in God so that you're not constantly thinking about your disease or about your problems or about yourself.
Really, honestly, honestly, you know, I put a beam on the quote on the member site that really matured in your relationship with God. Really is a constant battle of self against your selfishness. We are, we are living in a time where narcissism is growing.
That is the fastest growing identity that people will never identify with, but it's true. We are becoming a country of absolute self-centered narcissists. And just because we have a serious disease does not give us a right to be thinking about ourselves constantly.
So, matter of fact, when we have a serious disease, I would question that God allows things in our life so that we stop thinking about ourselves constantly and we start thinking about, you know, what is the legacy we want to live, you know, leave behind.
You know, there's a little guarantee that I'm going to live till tomorrow. What do I want people to think about me? If I died tomorrow, what are they going to think? Oh, well, he had cancer. And, you know, all he did, he was consumed with himself for the last three years.
Well, that's the kind of legacy I want my grandkids to think about their grandpa. I want my grandkids to think I love my grandpa. He's the best. He was the best grandpa in the world. He was always telling me stories. He was always doing stuff with me who'd always be babysitting with me. It always give me hugs and kisses.
He wasn't thinking about himself all the time. He was thinking about other people. And I'm talking to myself here, because I could be so just the same way, self-centered, narcissistic, but we are living in that culture that's driving us that way with social media, you know, and, you know,
just everything in our society. It's all me is and me is and me is and me is and it's a fulfilling second Timothy chapter three, where Paul told Timothy in the last of the last days people will be literally consumed with themselves. There will be lovers of themselves, lovers of money, boastful, proud, arrogant, disobedient, their parents, etc.
Well, that's the age we're living in. That's exactly what's going on. So that is a sympathetic tone in itself. You want to conquer your sympathetics. You need to conquer yourself and just chill out.
And you know, that has to do with your relationship with God. I just really believe that. And maybe some people are listening to this and you're not a believer.
Well, I just don't know how you go through life. You're certainly not going to go through it after life in a successful way that way. But you, we have to be holding on to the Lord and be trusted him in all things, even in difficult time, even in stress, even in seemingly failure of our success to treat our disease.
You've got to know where at his hands and in our days were numbered before the foundations of the earth were sent. So all right, I'll get off my soapbox there.